Ben has been a construction worker, a public high school teacher, a bike messenger, a laborer, but he says the best job he ever had was as a mover. This was in New York. Part of it, he says, was that the actual work with so straightforward. Part of it was that every day he was entering all these other people's lives, and he never knew where he would end up. It was so personal somehow, especially when the people hired movers to pack everything for them.
本曾做过建筑工人、公立高中老师、自行车快递员和劳工，但他却说他做过最好的工作是搬家工人。那是在纽约。他说，部分原因是因为这份工作非常直截了当。另一部分原因是，他每天都在介入别人的生活，而且永远不知道自己最后会去哪里。这在某种程度上是非常私人的，尤其是当人们雇佣搬家公司为他们打包所有物品时。
I mean, you were coming in at a special kind of time for people where they were pretty tense. And you got to see a lot very fast. You know, 9 o'clock in the morning you're bringing all these pads, and boxes, and straps, and everything into somebody's house as quickly as possible and taking a very quick look around their life. You get a very good idea very quickly of who they are.
我的意思是，你是进入了人们的一个特殊时期，他们当时非常紧张。你很快就能看到很多东西。你知道，早上9点，你带着所有的衬垫、盒子、带子和各种东西尽可能快地进入某人的房子，并非常快速地审视他们的生活。你很快就能对他们是什么样的人有一个很好的了解。
It's like being a spy.
这就像当间谍一样。
It felt a lot like being a spy, yeah.
感觉确实很像当间谍，没错。
When you're moving people all the time, is the thing that occurs to you how similar people's lives are or how different most of our lives are?
当你一直在帮人搬家时，你想到的是人们的生活有多么相似，还是我们大多数人的生活有多么不同？
Well most things that people move are pretty much the same. Everybody has a bed. Or at least in this part of the country everybody has a bed, and some books, and a lot of kitchenware, and generally a couch, and a few other things. Everyone tends to have a stereo. Everyone tends to have a television. And then somebody will stand out for one reason or another. They'll have a lot of music, like a lot CDs, or they'll have a collection of wines or something that we'll have to be real careful with. But there's not that much of a difference.
嗯，人们搬运的大多数东西都差不多。每个人都有床。或者至少在这个国家的这个地区，每个人都有床，还有一些书，大量的厨具，通常还有一个沙发，以及其他几样东西。每个人往往都有音响。每个人往往都有电视。然后有人会因为某种原因而脱颖而出。他们会有很多音乐，比如很多CD，或者他们会有珍藏的葡萄酒或某些我们需要格外小心的东西。但其实并没有太大的区别。
It's like what it reminds me of is you know when you're reading in People , or US Magazine , or any magazine, like any setting where you see inside the living rooms of the super rich and super famous. And I feel like usually when I see that I just think like that's it? Like that's what they've got? There's a coffee table, and a couple of chairs, and a couch, and a lamp. Like that's the best you can do? Like that's it?
这让我想起了你读《人物》杂志、《美国周刊》或任何杂志的时候，就像你在任何场景中看到超级富豪和超级名人的客厅内部一样。我觉得通常当我看到那些时，我只会想：就这样？他们就这些东西吗？有一个咖啡桌，几把椅子，一张沙发，还有一盏灯。这就是你们能做到的最好程度了？就这样？
But yeah, you'd be moving a couch. And it was sometimes, again, very rich people. And there's only so many configurations for things like couches.
但确实，你会搬沙发。而且有时，还是非常富有的人。对于沙发之类的东西，配置也就只有那么多。
One of the moments that was always kind of interesting, he says, was when people's stuff was all loaded into the truck, everything they had accumulated in this world stuffed into this tiny space. It's a humbling thing for a person.
他说，总有一些时刻很有趣，那就是当人们的所有东西都装进卡车时，他们在这个世界上积累的一切都塞进了这个狭小的空间里。这对一个人来说是一件让人感到卑微的事情。
It's a humbling thing. And they would get very upset often. And they would be very unsettled by that. And I could sort of understand that. Because, in a sense, everything that you'd worked for and sort of decided defined you was now sitting in this truck.
这是一件让人感到卑微的事情。而且他们往往会非常难过。他们会因此感到非常不安。我多少能理解这一点。因为在某种意义上，你为之奋斗并决定了你身份的一切现在都坐在那辆卡车里。
And generally if they were around, they'd look at us and the foremen would say, all right, we're going to go get lunch now because usually it would be in the middle of the day. But they would be staring at the truck. And you'd say, yeah, we're going to go get lunch, and we'll see you in Riverdale, or we'll see you on 89th Street, or whatever. And you'd look at them and they'd pause. Sometimes they'd be cool about it. But sometimes they wouldn't. They'd be like, but you will come there, won't you?
通常如果他们在场，他们会看着我们，领班会说，好了，我们要去吃午饭了，因为通常是在中午。但他们会盯着卡车看。你会说，是的，我们要去吃午饭了，我们在里弗代尔见，或者在第89街见，诸如此类。你看着他们，他们会停顿一下。有时他们会表现得很淡定。但有时他们不会。他们会说，但你们会去那里的，对吧？
They would say those words?
他们会说这些话吗？
Oh sure. People said that all the time. Or they'd say, can I ride with you, or where are you going to have lunch, or do you have to have lunch?
哦，当然。人们总是这么说。或者他们会说，我可以和你们一起坐车吗，或者你们打算去哪里吃午饭，或者你们非得吃午饭吗？
From their point of view, what's making them linger at the truck? Like what is it?
从他们的角度来看，是什么让他们在卡车旁徘徊？那到底是什么？
It is the anchor of home. Even for those few hours, especially for middle class people who have always lived somewhere or had a home, you're suddenly sort of rudderless. And I've seen a lot of that where people are just sort of standing around and they don't know what to do with themselves.
那是家的锚点。即使只是那几个小时，尤其是对于一直住在某处或拥有一个家的人们来说，你突然就变得没有方向感了。我见过很多这种情况，人们只是站在那里，不知道该怎么办。
We come into this world with nothing. We leave it with nothing. And on moving day we have nothing. It's an oddly naked moment, that day on which we make a transition from our old life and our old location to our new life and our new place, which is just one reason why everybody hates to move. Its freaky. It's freaky to go to something new. It's freaky to leave any place where you've been for a while. And the act of moving itself, it's a hardship.
我们来到这个世界时一无所有。我们离开时也一无所有。在搬家那天我们也是一无所有。这是一个奇怪的赤裸时刻，那一天我们从旧生活和旧地点过渡到新生活和新地方，这也是为什么每个人都讨厌搬家的原因之一。这很可怕。去到一个新地方很可怕。离开你待了一段时间的任何地方都很可怕。而搬家这一行为本身，就是一种艰辛。
Today on our program, we bring you three stories of people who did not want to move at all, but circumstance forced their hands. In Act One, an act that we call, Sleeping in Mommy and Daddy's Room, a family finds a way to move without moving by simply moving back into the house where the wife in the family grew up. In Act Two, Deal of a Lifetime, a woman buys a house from a man who simply does not move out ever. In Act Three, To a De-luxe Apartment in the Sky, a man makes a move, but it takes him eight years to do it.
今天在我们的节目中，我们为您带来三个关于人们根本不想搬家，但环境迫使他们不得不搬家的故事。在第一幕中，我们称之为“睡在爸爸妈妈的房间里”，一个家庭找到了一种通过搬回妻子成长的房子来“不搬家”的搬家方式。在第二幕中，“一生一世的交易”，一个女人从一个根本不打算搬走的人手中买下了一栋房子。在第三幕中，“搬到天上的豪华公寓”，一个男人搬了家，但他花了八年时间才完成。
Stick around. You're listening to This American Life from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
别走开。您正在收听的是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Act One, Sleeping in Mommy and Daddy's Room. This is the story of people wanting to change and not wanting to change at all at the same time, of a house that gets built and a house that gets moved all in pursuit of not making a new home at all. Susan Burton tells the story.
第一幕，睡在爸爸妈妈的房间里。这是一个关于人们想要改变却同时又一点也不想改变的故事，关于一栋被建造并被搬迁的房子的故事，所有这些都是为了不去建立一个真正的新家。苏珊·伯顿讲述了这个故事。
I went to Wayzata, Minnesota to meet Mimi Bendickson and watch three men move her childhood home. Wayzata is just west of Minneapolis. It's a wealthy suburb, hedges and horse stables. And as I drive over to Mimi's, I have a hard time imagining that any of the houses I'm passing could be uprooted. They're sewn into groomed lawns, penned in by giant trees.
我去了明尼苏达州的韦扎塔见咪咪·本迪克森，看着三个男人搬走她童年的家。韦扎塔就在明尼阿波利斯的西边。这是一个富裕的郊区，有树篱和马厩。当我开车去咪咪家时，我很难想象我经过的任何房子会被连根拔起。它们被缝在修剪整齐的草坪里，被参天大树包围。
So I'm startled when I near the top of the hill and see an enormous pink brick house in the middle of a pasture, clearly on its way somewhere. And though it's suspended 12 feet above the ground jacked up on wheels, there are still flowers in the fixtures next to the front door.
所以，当我接近山顶，看到牧场中间有一栋巨大的粉红色砖房时，我感到很吃惊，它显然正在去某处的路上。尽管它被架在轮子上悬在离地12英尺的空中，前门旁边的装置里仍然有花。
I mean it's a really strange sensation to see a house being supported like this.
我的意思是，看到一栋房子这样被支撑着，感觉真的很奇怪。
This is Mimi.
这是咪咪。
I mean, it looks fragile in a way to be up in the air. To me, because the house has personality, it looks kind of lonely and confused. It's not where it should be. I keep adding personality to it, and thinking it must just wonder what in the world are you guys doing to me. But in the long run it will be thankful I hope.
我的意思是，悬在空中看起来很脆弱。对我来说，因为这房子有独特的个性，它看起来有点孤独和困惑。它不在它应该在的地方。我不断地给它赋予个性，想着它一定在纳闷你们这些人到底在对我做什么。但我希望从长远来看，它会心存感激。
It's early in the day, just past 9:00, and Mimi's carrying a bakery box tied with red ribbon. The movers take a break, eat a doughnut, and the house looming over us, I chat with Larry, the head of the crew.
那天很早，刚过9点，咪咪拿着一个系着红丝带的烘焙盒。搬家工人们休息一下，吃个甜甜圈，我们在笼罩着我们的房子旁，我和负责该团队的拉里聊天。
We're 40 feet wide. The main part of the house is 60 feet long, and then on one end has a sunroom that extends another 15 feet. And on the back end, a mud room so-called, and that sticks out 24 feet.
我们有40英尺宽。房子的主体部分有60英尺长，一端还有一个延伸了15英尺的阳光房。在后端，有一个所谓的泥房，它突出了24英尺。
And how much does the house weigh?
这房子有多重？
We weighed 240 tons here.
我们在这里称重是240吨。
This house is massive by moving standards. Most houses weight only 100, maybe 130 tons, Larry tells me.
按照搬家标准，这栋房子是巨大的。拉里告诉我，大多数房子只有100吨，也许130吨重。
The movers finish up breakfast, slip the doughnut box onto a steel beam underneath the front steps, and as their winches begin to whir, Mimi tells me the history of the house, which is stranger than you might think.
搬家工人们吃完早餐，把甜甜圈盒子滑到前台阶下的钢梁上，随着绞盘开始嗡嗡作响，咪咪告诉我这栋房子的历史，这比你想象的还要奇怪。
Mimi's parents first built this house in Southern Illinois. They lived there for several years, and then her father was transferred to Minneapolis. The family bought some land in Wayzata and decided to replicate the Illinois house exactly.
咪咪的父母最初是在伊利诺伊州南部建造这栋房子的。他们在那里住了几年，然后她父亲被调到了明尼阿波利斯。家里人在韦扎塔买了一些土地，决定完全复制伊利诺伊州的房子。
It's amazing. There's the same wallpaper in my bedroom, same wallpaper in the kitchen. Everything was the same-- the colors, the carpeting, the paint. It may sound really silly, but we'd only had the house for five years, and we'd loved it so much. And so our neighbors from Illinois would come visit us. They said it was just the oddest thing because you felt like you could walk out the door and walk home. It was identical. So it really was like walking into the same home.
这太神奇了。我的卧室里有一样的墙纸，厨房里也是一样的。一切都是一样的——颜色、地毯、油漆。这听起来可能很傻，但我们只住了五年，我们非常爱它。所以我们在伊利诺伊州的邻居来看望我们时，他们说这简直是最奇怪的事情，因为你会觉得你可以走出那扇门然后走回家。它是一模一样的。所以真的就像走进同一个家一样。
The same crew moved us into this house. And they stood at the front door and said, you've got to be kidding.
同一个团队把我们搬进了这栋房子。他们站在前门口说，你们一定是在开玩笑。
This is Mimi's mother, Adrienne.
这是咪咪的母亲，艾德丽安。
OK guys, that bedroom goes up on the right, that goes in the living room over here. They knew the house, and it was identical. And luckily we were able to reproduce everything, the wallpaper, the drapes, the carpeting, just about everything.
好了伙计们，那间卧室放在右边，那个放在这边的客厅。他们了解这栋房子，它是一模一样的。幸运的是，我们能够复制一切，墙纸、窗帘、地毯，几乎所有东西。
And they lived happily ever after, for 25 years anyway, until certain small things began to bother them, little things about certain rooms. It's as if the house they were living in began to coexist in their minds with the second house, an imaginary house that was just slightly more perfect than the one they actually inhabited. And at some point, they decided they wanted to live in that other house. Here's Truck, Mimi's father.
他们从此过上了幸福的生活，至少过了25年，直到某些小事开始困扰他们，关于某些房间的小事。就好像他们住的房子在他们的脑海中开始与第二栋房子并存，那是一个虚构的房子，比他们实际居住的房子稍微完美一点点。在某个时候，他们决定他们想住在那个其他的房子里。这是咪咪的父亲，卡车。
And we really said to the architect, we've lived in the family room for two houses, I suppose a total of 30 years. And if this family room was just a few inches, or feet, or something different, or the fireplace would settle a bit left, or right, or something like that it would be perfect.
我们确实对建筑师说，我们在这个家庭室住了两栋房子，总共大约30年了。如果这个家庭室稍微有几英寸、几英尺或什么地方不同，或者壁炉稍微向左、向右移动一点，或者类似的东西，那就完美了。
But they found it would be more expensive to renovate than to tear the house down and build another brand new. What to do? The thought of bulldozing the house was so upsetting that they could hardly talk about it. Mimi's mother, Adrienne.
但他们发现翻新的费用比拆掉房子再建一个全新的要贵。怎么办？想到推土机推平房子就让他们非常不安，以至于他们几乎无法谈论它。咪咪的母亲，艾德丽安。
Mimi had the fourth grandchild. Mimi and Mark had the fourth grandchild. And all the others had had a really neat experience, we think, with us in that house on that location. And I really felt badly that Adie would never have an opportunity to know that house like everybody else. And this gave us an opportunity to have her know the house too. Isn't this silly? You don't think of how much is in your home until you lose it.
咪咪有了第四个孙子。咪咪和马克有了第四个孙子。而其他所有人都认为他们在那个位置的那个房子里有过一段非常美好的经历。我真的感到很遗憾，艾迪永远没有机会像其他人那样了解那栋房子。这给了我们一个机会，让她也能了解那栋房子。这不是很傻吗？在你失去它之前，你不会想到家里有多少东西。
Then Mimi's husband suggested that the family move the house, that he, and Mimi, and their children could live in it. Since the structure was too big to take onto county roads, they would tug it onto an empty field elsewhere on the property, just a five-minute walk away from the original site, the site on which Mimi's parents will rebuild their old house, with subtle changes, this fall.
后来咪咪的丈夫建议全家把房子搬走，他和咪咪以及他们的孩子可以住在里面。由于结构太大，无法上县道，他们会把它拖到房产上别处的空地上，距离原址只有五分钟的步行路程，这个旧址上，咪咪的父母将在今年秋天进行细微的改动后重建他们的旧房子。
What about a house could mean so much to a family, mean so much that they'd build it three times, scoop it out of the ground, prop it on trailers, drag it through the pasture, carry it with them wherever they go? Architecturally, there isn't anything extraordinary about the house. Adrienne and Truck found the floor plan in a magazine. It's a pretty two-story with four bedrooms, a little formal looking. If, in the 1970s, you spent any time in a country club suburb, you drove your station wagon past a lot of houses like this. Adrienne offers one explanation for her attachment to the house.
房子有什么能对一个家庭如此重要，以至于他们要建它三次，把它从地里铲出来，撑在拖车上，拖过牧场，无论走到哪里都带着它？从建筑学上讲，这栋房子并没有什么特别之处。艾德丽安和卡车是在杂志上找到这个平面图的。这是一栋漂亮的双层住宅，有四个卧室，看起来有点正式。如果你在1970年代在乡村俱乐部的郊区待过一段时间，你就开着旅行车经过过很多这样的房子。艾德丽安对她对房子的依恋给出了一个解释。
I don't like to change. And I'm tedious to the point of-- anyway, I'm tedious. But when we come to a conclusion on something we are so married to that idea, and then we don't want to revisit it again. So yeah, people thought we were strange because lots of friends of ours have the ability and the inclination to completely redecorate, and re-carpet, and do all these things about every ten years. We don't feel the need to do that. And I don't know if it's laziness. I think it's we are really happy with what we have.
我不喜欢改变。而且我厌烦到——不管怎样，我很厌烦。但当我们对某件事达成结论时，我们是如此忠于那个想法，然后我们就不想再重新审视它了。所以是的，人们认为我们很奇怪，因为我们的很多朋友都有能力和倾向每十年左右彻底重新装饰、更换地毯，做所有这些事情。我们觉得没有必要那样做。我不知道这是否是懒惰。我想是因为我们对所拥有的东西真的很高兴。
And at some level, the reason this family keeps remaking the same house is as simple as they're happy together in that home. They have fun there. This is not a family for whom Sunday dinner together is an obligation. They like being together. And they like being together around their house. When I suggest to Mimi that for many people, moving back into a childhood home might be painful, bittersweet, it's almost like she doesn't understand what I mean. Well, maybe if someone had died there, she says.
在某种程度上，这个家庭不断重造同一栋房子的原因很简单，他们在那家里很幸福。他们在那里玩得很开心。这并不是一个把周日晚餐看作义务的家庭。他们喜欢在一起。他们喜欢围绕着他们的房子在一起。当我向咪咪暗示，对于许多人来说，搬回童年的家可能是痛苦的，苦乐参半，她似乎几乎不明白我的意思。嗯，如果有人在那里去世了，她可能会说。
And there's one more reason why the house means so much. In the movie of this family's life, in the scene where the dying man says, Rosebud, the name Mimi's family would say is
这栋房子意义重大的原因还有一个。在这个家庭生活的电影中，在那个垂死的人说“玫瑰花蕾”的场景里，咪咪的家人会说的名字是
Highcroft.
海克罗夫特。
Truck's ancestors include some old money Minnesotans who owned a historic home called well, Highcroft, a 40,000 square foot mansion on Lake Minnetonka. Truck pages through a green leather album showing me photographs. The house had its own power plant, a commercial laundry on the first floor. It was torn down in the 1950s, the land sold off and divided up into separate plots just four miles from where the family lives now.
卡车的祖先包括一些明尼苏达州的老钱家族，他们拥有一座名为“海克罗夫特”的历史性住宅，这是明尼通卡湖上一座40,000平方英尺的豪宅。卡车翻阅着一本绿色的皮质相册给我看照片。这房子有自己的发电厂，一楼有商业洗衣房。它在1950年代被拆除，土地被卖掉并划分成独立的土地，距离这个家庭现在居住的地方仅四英里。
Everyone makes sure that I know about Highcroft, brings it up early in the conversation. The family clearly feels the story explains something about them.
每个人都确保我知道海克罗夫特，在谈话早期就提起它。这个家庭显然觉得这个故事解释了关于他们的一些事情。
Anyway, the last night in early January, 1952, Granddad was leaving for the train station. And the staff of Highcroft, and there was this enormous big house had generally more than one butler, and more than one cook, and upstairs maids, and downstairs maids, and a manager of the house, and everybody else, the chauffeur, they lined up to say goodbye to Granddad. And I will never ever forget how broken up I was to watch this old man who was about 85 years old say goodbye to what was his history.
总之，1952年1月初的最后一晚，爷爷正要出发去火车站。海克罗夫特的员工——那是一座巨大的房子，通常不止一个管家，不止一个厨师，楼上的女仆，楼下的女仆，管家经理，以及其他人，司机，他们排队向爷爷告别。我永远永远不会忘记，看着这个85岁左右的老人告别他曾经的历史，我是多么伤心。
You grow up hearing your family's stories--
你成长过程中会听到家人的故事——
This is Mimi again.
这是咪咪。
--and they're all passed on. Stories take on a life of their own. There's always been these stories. And it probably makes this Highcroft house even grander than it was. Who knows? I mean, I don't know. But I think it was kind of weird that they didn't think of a way to save it. So maybe that's like a little voice in the back of my head, that it's pretty hard to lose something because it's gone forever.
——它们都被传下来了。故事有了自己的生命。一直都有这些故事。这可能让海克罗夫特房子比它实际的样子还要宏伟。谁知道呢？我的意思是，我不知道。但我认为他们没有想到保存它的方法真是太奇怪了。所以也许那是我脑后的小声音，失去一样东西是很难的，因为它永远消失了。
There was a choice about Highcroft, and the family believes it chose wrong. And this seems to be more painful than the absence itself. And what they fear is forgetting. Mimi tells me that once something is gone it's hard to remember it again, that already it's hard to imagine the big pink brick house on its old site. And building the same thing every time is a way of guarding against forgetting. It's almost as if the family thinks that if they live their lives in different rooms all of their memories would disappear.
关于海克罗夫特有一个选择，而这个家庭认为他们选错了。这似乎比缺席本身更痛苦。他们担心的是遗忘。咪咪告诉我，一旦一样东西消失了，就很难再记住它，已经很难想象旧址上那座巨大的粉红色砖房了。每次都建造同样的东西是防止遗忘的一种方式。这几乎就像这个家庭认为，如果他们生活在不同的房间里，所有的记忆就会消失。
There's not one single aspect of that house that is that important to me, but it's what happened in that house, which is why we have built it twice, I think. It works well, yes, but it's the things that happened there, the milestones in our lives, the preparations for two weddings, the children being born, the baptism luncheons, the Easter, the Christmases. Those are the things that really, if we were in a different house altogether, that would all be lost.
那栋房子里没有哪个单一的方面对我那么重要，但重要的是在那栋房子里发生的事情，我想这就是为什么我们建了它两次。它运行良好，是的，但重要的是那里发生的事情，我们生命中的里程碑，两场婚礼的准备，孩子的出生，洗礼午宴，复活节，圣诞节。如果我们在完全不同的房子里，所有这些就都会丢失了。
Why shouldn't you be able to hold onto what happens inside a room? Mimi's family simply takes to an extreme a feeling a lot of people have about homes they've lived in and moved away from. A house can inspire a kind of longing. But you can love a house maybe too much, which was something Mimi had to think about. Because she was essentially asking her husband, Mark, to move into her childhood home from his childhood home, which is where they live now.
为什么你不能留住发生在房间里的事情呢？咪咪的家庭只是把许多人对他们住过和搬离的家的一种感觉推向了极端。房子可以激发一种渴望。但你爱房子可能爱得太深了，这是咪咪不得不思考的事情。因为她基本上是在要求她的丈夫马克从他童年的家搬到她童年的家，那是他们现在住的地方。
Mimi and I drive out to Maple Plain. It's only 15 minutes from Wayzata, but more rural and more working class, low-slung warehouses, a beer distributor, a sign that says, chainsaw sale on now. We pass Mark's parents house-- the one he actually grew up in-- take a left and we're at Mark and Mimi's house, high on a bluff, looking around at miles of pretty plains and wetlands.
咪咪和我开车去枫平原。距离韦扎塔只有15分钟路程，但更偏远，更像工薪阶层，低矮的仓库，一个啤酒分销商，一个牌子上写着“电锯热卖中”。我们经过马克父母的房子——他真正长大的那个——向左转，我们就到了马克和咪咪的房子，高耸在悬崖上，望着数英里的美丽平原和湿地。
From here we can see where Mark's sister lives. She and the rest of his family helped him move this house here, put down the driveway, plant the grass. Mark's so easygoing that if he's upset about leaving this world he's put so much effort into constructing there's no way to tell.
从这里我们可以看到马克的姐姐住在哪里。她和他的家人们帮他把房子搬到这里，铺了车道，种了草。马克性格太随和了，如果他对离开这个他投入了如此多努力建设的世界感到不安，也根本看不出来。
Mimi was very open-minded to move out here with me away from civilization, and to move into my home that had my look to it.
咪咪非常开明，愿意随我搬到这里远离文明，搬进我有我个人风格的家。
And history to it.
还有它的历史。
Well, and now I mean the least I can do is cheerfully follow her to our next step.
嗯，现在我的意思是，我能做的最起码的事就是欢快地跟随她走下我们的下一步。
This is as much as I can ever get Mark to say about the move. As the three of us talk he seems reluctant to bring up anything that might upset anyone. He says he's looking forward to being in a better school district, closer to restaurants, to setting up his music studio, but Mimi notices something he's leaving out.
这就是马克关于搬家所能说的全部。当我们三个人交谈时，他似乎不愿提起任何可能让任何人不安的事情。他说他期待去一个更好的学区，更靠近餐馆，设立他的音乐工作室，但咪咪注意到了他遗漏的东西。
You've never once mentioned the house, like how you feel about the house itself. I've never even asked you that. Uh oh. We're going to have to put the house up for sale. But I mean how you feel about the house, not just moving?
你从来没提过房子，比如你对房子本身的感觉。我甚至从来没问过你。噢哦。我们得把房子拿去卖了。但我的意思是你是怎么看待房子的，不仅仅是搬家？
I love it. I don't think that's an issue. I like this house where we are now. This other one is better.
我爱它。我不认为这是一个问题。我喜欢我们现在住的这个房子。另外一个更好。
This isn't the answer Mimi's looking for. And they go around on this until finally Mimi points out that Mark would've been happy to stay in their current house.
这不是咪咪想要的答案。他们在这个问题上兜圈子，直到最后咪咪指出，如果留在他们现在的房子里，马克也会很高兴。
And this has sort of always been a touchy issue. But this was never my house for my life. And I always was looking to the next step. And moving here was always, to me, coming into your world for a lot of reasons. This is where Mark had his single life. This is where Mark dated other people. This is where his whole family was involved. This has always been our house, but it's Mark's house.
这一直是一个敏感的问题。但这从来都不是我为了我的生活而住的房子。我总是期待着下一步。搬到这里对我来说，因为很多原因，总是走进你的世界。这是马克过单身生活的地方。这是马克和其他人约会的地方。这是他整个家庭参与的地方。这一直是我们家，但这是马克的家。
I'm kind of making it seem like it's black and white. And I will be really sad to leave here too. But I'm so excited for the other. And I've always been dreaming about the next step where Mark saw his dreams for this place. And so that's hard. I mean he's got paths that he made for the kids to walk in. Well that's hard to give up.
我有点让它看起来非黑即白。离开这里我也会真的很伤心。但我对另一个充满了期待。我一直梦想着下一步，而马克在这里实现了他的梦想。所以这很难。我的意思是，他为孩子们铺设了小路。嗯，这很难放弃。
Mimi starts to cry. And I turn off the tape recorder. And she looks out the window and says, it's hard to see somebody's dreams not be able to happen.
咪咪开始哭泣。我关掉了录音机。她看着窗外说，看着某人的梦想无法实现是很难受的。
There are two parts to a move, what you take with you and what you leave behind. And the hardest thing for Mark isn't coming into Mimi's world, it's what he's giving up.
搬家有两个部分，你带走的东西和你留下的东西。对马克来说，最难的不是进入咪咪的世界，而是他正在放弃的东西。
It's hard to imagine moving an entire house, and not many people do it. There aren't firm figures, but by one estimate, 10,000 structures of all kinds are moved each year. The guy moving Mimi's house, Larry Stubbs of Stubbs Building Movers, recently made the Guinness Book of World Records when he moved the Shubert Theatre in Minneapolis.
很难想象搬动一整栋房子，而且没几个人会这么做。没有确切的数据，但据一项估计，每年有10,000种各种各样的建筑被搬迁。搬动咪咪房子的人，斯塔布斯建筑搬运公司的拉里·斯塔布斯，最近在搬运明尼阿波利斯的舒伯特剧院时创下了吉尼斯世界纪录。
To move Mimi's childhood home, Larry started by digging a moat around the house, inserted jacks at the edges of the building, cracked it off its foundation, pumped it up into the air. Then he stuck a complicated network of support beams and wheeled dollies underneath. It took less than a week to pull the house close to its new site. Then Mark and his father got in excavators and dug a big hole, graded an incline down into it. The house gets rolled into the hole. A foundation is built under it. The support system is taken away.
为了搬动咪咪童年的家，拉里先在房子周围挖了一条护城河，在建筑边缘插入千斤顶，将其从地基上裂开，泵入空中。然后他在下面塞进了一套复杂的支撑梁和轮式小车网络。不到一周时间就完成了将房子拉到新址附近的工作。然后马克和他的父亲开着挖掘机挖了一个大洞，平整了一个斜坡进入其中。房子被滚进坑里。下面建起了地基。支撑系统被移走。
As they pull the house into the hole, you can see the wheels turning under it. But its progress is so incremental, so graceful, that you can't actually perceive the move unless you go away for an hour and return, as Mimi and I do, to see the house turned at an angle rounding a bend, the doughnut box from this morning still sitting upon a beam
当他们把房子拉进坑里时，你可以看到下面的轮子在转动。但它的进度非常渐进，非常优雅，以至于如果你不走开一个小时再回来，你就无法感知到搬迁，就像咪咪和我做的那样，去看看房子被转了一个角度绕过一个弯，今天早上的甜甜圈盒子仍然坐在一根梁上。
Mimi gets out her cell phone and calls friends and family, tells them to come over. It looks like today's the day Larry's going to finish, fix the house in its final spot. I climb up in a truck cab with a mover named Dave, who's winching a cable attached to the house around a giant spool.
咪咪拿出手机给朋友和家人打电话，告诉他们过来。看起来今天就是拉里要完成工作，把房子固定在最终位置的日子。我爬进一个叫戴夫的搬家工人的卡车驾驶室，他正用绞盘把系在房子上的一根电缆绕在一个巨大的线轴上。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE], Dave.
[听不清的短语]，戴夫。
All right, did you hear what he said?
好吧，你听到他说的了吗？
What did he say?
他说什么？
Go easy on that one.
那个稍微慢一点。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
[听不清的短语]。
We might be done. That might be it here.
我们可能完成了。可能就是这样了。
What makes you think that?
你为什么这么想？
Well we're both letting our cables down. So let's go find out.
嗯，我们都在放下电缆。所以我们去看看吧。
And all of a sudden it's in place, and we're not on a job site zigzagged by bulldozer tracks but in a front yard. Mimi's mother, Adrienne, arrives and stands before the house, right where the circular driveway will be, holding her granddaughter, Adie.
突然之间，它就到位了，我们不再是在布满推土机痕迹的工作现场，而是在前院。咪咪的母亲，艾德丽安到达了，站在房子前面，就在环形车道所在的位置，抱着她的孙女艾迪。
It's just a little emotional. It's all of a sudden not our house anymore. Now it's this generation's house, and it's wonderful. Yeah. This is not Grandpa's house anymore or Grandma's house. This is your house. It's in a new spot. Yes.
这有点感人。突然之间它不再是我们的房子了。现在它是这一代的房子，这太棒了。是的。这不再是爷爷的房子或奶奶的房子了。这是你们的房子。它在新的位置。是的。
Here we walk in and it's kind of a mess. And aqua from 20 years ago. But this is the kitchen.
我们走进去，这里有点乱。还有20年前的水彩色。但这就是厨房。
Mimi and I climb up a ladder and through a hole poked into the floor of the mud room. I feel as if we're entering an exhibit, something mounted, a museum piece.
咪咪和我爬上梯子，穿过泥房地板上戳出的一个洞。我觉得我们好像进入了一个展品，某种安装好的博物馆藏品。
The interior of the house is so vintage 70s that it's a little spooky. I half expect one of the girls from the movie The Virgin Suicides to lean over the banister in a gauzy prom dress. We stand in the wood paneled family room talking about Mimi's plans to redecorate and her memories of the place.
房子的内部是非常复古的70年代风格，有点阴森。我半期待《处女之死》里的女孩会穿着薄纱舞会礼服靠在楼梯栏杆上。我们站在木板覆盖的家庭室里，谈论着咪咪重新装饰的计划以及她对这个地方的记忆。
This is the room where the picture was taken when Mark proposed to me. We came over and woke my mom up and took pictures in here. It was like 1:00 in the morning. But this is the room that, for me, has caused the most agonizing over how to make it special and us in a new feel but not too different.
这是拍马克向我求婚时的照片的房间。我们过来把妈妈叫醒，在这里拍了照片。当时大约凌晨1点。但这对我来说，是让我最痛苦的房间，如何让它变得特别，让它有一种新的感觉，但又不过于不同。
To Mimi, this is the central tension of the project. She's trying to preserve something, but change it at the same time. We finish the tour of the first floor and head upstairs.
对咪咪来说，这是这个项目的核心张力。她试图保留一些东西，但同时又改变它。我们完成了对一楼的参观，走上楼。
You know when you walk up the stairs in your house and just sort of know exactly how long it's going to take. Do you have that feeling like when you walk up the stairs?
你知道当你走上家里的楼梯时，会确切地知道需要多长时间。你走上楼梯时有那种感觉吗？
Yeah, and what's funny is I always walk up and go this way because that's my old room. I never ever would take somebody to the master bedroom first because I've never done that, which I guess I hadn't thought about until now. Anyway, this is my brother and mine, this is the bathroom we shared growing up.
是的，有趣的是我总是走上来然后走这边，因为那是我的旧房间。我从来不会先带人去主卧，因为我从没那样做过，我直到现在才想到这一点。总之，这是我和我兄弟的，这是我们一起长大的浴室。
I tried to figure out a polite way to ask Mimi, won't it be a little odd to be sleeping with your husband in your parents bedroom? When I finally do, Mimi is surprisingly unfazed by the notion. It simply doesn't bother her that much. In fact, she said, she and Mark have a four poster bed just like her parents.
我试着想出一个礼貌的方法问咪咪，和丈夫睡在你父母的卧室里会不会有点奇怪？当我最终问出来时，咪咪对这个想法感到意外地镇定。这根本没怎么困扰她。事实上，她说，她和马克有一张和她父母一模一样的四柱床。
Mark comes inside with Adie and Mimi takes him to see the view from the kitchen windows. It's the moment in the move when  a house officially changes hands and the new owners walk around whispering, exploring. And what's amazing is that Mimi can actually have this experience in this house, given the fact that she lived here for 18 years.
马克带着艾迪进来了，咪咪带他去看从厨房窗户看到的景色。这是搬家过程中房子正式易主、新主人到处低声探索的时刻。令人惊奇的是，鉴于咪咪在这里住了18年，她竟然能在这栋房子里有这种体验。
She tours the rooms looking for little reassurances, that it will feel normal here, that it wasn't a mistake to move the house. And what's most comforting to Mimi is that it feels a lot like what it was.
她参观着房间，寻找一点保证，保证这里会感觉正常，搬动房子不是一个错误。对咪咪来说，最令人欣慰的是，它感觉很像过去的样子。
It doesn't feel weird anymore. Looking out the windows, it doesn't feel odd anymore. I don't know. Doesn't it kind of look like it's the same view?
它不再感觉奇怪了。看着窗外，它不再感觉奇怪了。我不知道。它看起来不就像是同一个景色吗？
Well it's a nice view.
嗯，景色不错。
But doesn't it just feel like it did because you're facing the same direction and you're looking at the same green and the same trees in the back?
但它感觉不就像原来那样吗，因为你面对的是同一个方向，你看的是同样的绿色和后面同样的树？
Later in the evening, I sit in the yard and think about how F. Scott Fitzgerald set some of his short stories here, in the wealthy corners of Minnesota, amidst lake houses and broad lawns. The story Mimi's dad told me about his grandfather's last night at Highcroft has a plot that's pure Fitzgerald, someone riding away on a snowy night in a Pullman car taking a last look at the fine old mansion, the receding past.
傍晚时分，我坐在院子里思考F·斯科特·菲茨杰拉德是如何把他的短篇小说设定在这里的，在明尼苏达州富裕的角落，在湖畔别墅和宽阔的草坪之间。咪咪爸爸告诉我的关于他爷爷在海克罗夫特最后一晚的故事，情节纯粹是菲茨杰拉德式的，有人在雪夜骑车离开，坐着普尔曼车厢最后一次看那精致的老宅，那消退的过去。
In an actual Fitzgerald story, say Winter Dreams , that past would be lost forever. And at some point the protagonist, in that one a Minnesota golf caddy, would rub his eyes in a panic trying to conjure it up again, reinhabit that world, and be devastated by his inability to summon it back.
在真正的菲茨杰拉德故事中，比如《冬天的梦》，那段过去将永远丢失。在某个时候，主角——那个故事里是一个明尼苏达的高尔夫球童——会惊恐地揉着眼睛，试图再次勾勒出它，重新住进那个世界，并因无法召回它而感到崩溃。
But Fitzgerald would have had to write Mimi's story as a fairy tale. She's done the thing that's impossible, packed the one thing you can't take with you. She's kept the past accessible for her whole family. They have all of the rooms, all of the years of their lives. They can literally step back into something a lot of people strain to recapture. And she's been able to do this because, unlike Fitzgerald's characters, unlike so many of us, she's never left home.
但菲茨杰拉德必须把咪咪的故事写成童话。她做到了不可能的事情，打包了你不能带走的一样东西。她让整个家庭都能接触到过去。他们拥有所有的房间，所有的岁月。他们真的可以跨回许多人努力夺回的东西。她之所以能做到这一点，是因为与菲茨杰拉德的角色不同，与我们许多人不同，她从未离开过家。
Susan Burton.
苏珊·伯顿。
Coming up, how to sell your home, make thousands and thousands of dollars, and never move out. That's right, a case study. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，如何出售你的家，赚取成千上万的美元，却永远不用搬走。没错，一个案例研究。那是来自国际公共广播电台的节目，稍后继续。
[MUSIC - "YOU'D BE SO NICE TO COME HOME TO" BY THE AL COHN AND ZOOT SIMS QUINTET]
[音乐 - "YOU'D BE SO NICE TO COME HOME TO" BY THE AL COHN AND ZOOT SIMS QUINTET]
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different stories on that theme. Today's program, how to move without really moving, stories of people who do not want change in their lives, but then events force them to change and how they try to hold onto what they already know and love despite that.
这是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目是关于如何搬家而无需真正搬家，关于那些生活中不想改变，但随后事件迫使他们改变，以及尽管如此，他们如何试图紧紧抓住他们已经知道和热爱的东西的故事。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program, Act Two, Deal of a Lifetime. The typical way that it goes when somebody moves is that they move into the new house or apartment and the old occupant moves out. Sarah Koenig has this story of a situation where the new mover moved in, but at that point the process came to a dead halt.
我们进入了节目的第二幕，“一生一世的交易”。有人搬家时，典型的方式是搬进新房子或新公寓，旧住户搬走。莎拉·柯尼格有这样一个故事，情况是新搬家者搬了进来，但此时过程陷入了死胡同。
My stepsister, Rue, wanted a house in Sag Harbor, New York badly. But the former fishing village is now the artsiest of the tourist towns that make up the Hamptons, and she couldn't really afford it. Then one day she found out about a lovely house on Main Street listed for two prices. The more expensive listing included a house, a shed, and a little garden. The cheaper listing included a house, a shed, a little garden, and Ned.
我的继姐瑞，非常渴望在纽约萨格港有一栋房子。但这个前渔村现在是汉普顿组成的一系列旅游城镇中最具艺术气息的一个，她根本负担不起。有一天，她发现主街上有一栋可爱的房子，列出了两个价格。较昂贵的清单包括房子、棚子和一个小花园。较便宜的清单包括房子、棚子、一个小花园，还有内德。
Well, the way I identify Ned is my man. People laugh at this, but he really is mine. He's the man that came with the house.
嗯，我识别内德的方式是“我的男人”。人们对此感到好笑，但他确实是我的。他是随房子而来的那个人。
The deal was this. Rue moved into her dream house at $110,000 discount. The catch was Ned, an elderly, sick man who sold the house cheap on one condition, that he never have to move out. Rue lives in the upstairs apartment. Ned lives in the more spacious downstairs, where he will stay until he dies.
交易是这样的。瑞以11万美元的折扣搬进了她梦寐以求的房子。条件是内德，一个年老、生病、以一个条件低价卖掉房子的男人：他永远不必搬出。瑞住在楼上的公寓里。内德住在更宽敞的楼下，他将一直住到去世为止。
While Ned is working in his little downtown shop, which sells classical music CDs, Rue gives us a tour. We're coming into Ned's portion of the house, which is where he's lived for I think maybe 20 years, I'm not sure, and which is good for him too because he's older. It's all on street level. He doesn't have to climb any stairs. And also he's lost a lot of his sight, which is one reason why he really didn't want to leave this house.
当内德在市区的小店里工作——那里卖古典音乐CD——瑞带我们参观。我们进入了内德那部分的房子，我想他大概在那里住了20年，我不确定，这对他也很好，因为他年纪大了。它都在街道层面上。他不必爬任何楼梯。而且他的视力也失去了很多，这也是他真的不想离开这栋房子的一个原因。
Unlike the mansions across the street, this house isn't big or fancy. It was built perhaps 100 years ago for the workers in the local watchcase factory. When she bought it, Rue was 36 and single. The idea that she could inhabit only two rooms of her new house didn't seem problematic. What she did not foresee was that in the space of a year, she would acquire a puppy, a husband and a baby.
与街对面的豪宅不同，这房子既不大也不华丽。它大概是100年前为当地表壳厂的工人们建造的。当她买下它时，瑞36岁，单身。她认为自己只能占据新房子的两个房间似乎不是什么问题。她没有预见到的是，在一年之内，她会得到一只小狗，一个丈夫和一个婴儿。
She tries to focus on the deal's advantages. The cramped quarters have taught her to resolve fights with her husband rather than flee them, she says. And Rue, extravagantly messy in her youth, has now taken to watching Martha Stewart's TV show at 9:00 AM, and has learned helpful tips for maximizing space. Still, she can't deny that the population boom in her apartment has made Ned's downstairs look especially attractive.
她试图专注于这笔交易的优势。她说，局促的空间教会了她如何与丈夫解决争吵而不是逃避。而年轻时极其邋遢的瑞，现在开始在早上9点观看玛莎·斯图尔特的电视节目，并学会了最大化空间的有用技巧。不过，她无法否认，她公寓里的人口爆炸使内德的楼下看起来特别有吸引力。
And this is the living room.
这是客厅。
Is this where you would have the bedroom if you were down here? Would you use that as the master bedroom?
如果你住在这里，你会把卧室设在哪里？你会把它当作主卧吗？
Well, actually I think I would change the whole back of the house if I were down here. As you might guess, I've had a few imaginings of what I'd like to do with the space down here, but not too many. I don't like to get carried away with myself prematurely. These are all terrible things to think of.
嗯，事实上我想如果我住在这里，我会改变整个房子的后面。正如你可能猜到的，我对如何处理下面的空间有一些想象，但不多。我不喜欢过早地让自己得意忘形。这些都是很可怕的想法。
Why are they terrible things to think of?
为什么它们是可怕的想法？
Well, I don't know. There's this vulture-like aspect of it when you start talking about what you'd like to do. I mean there's no getting around that. How can I talk about what I'd like to do? I'd never get to do it until he's moved on from this world.
嗯，我不知道。当你开始谈论你想做什么时，有一种秃鹫般的感觉。我的意思是，这无法绕过。我怎么能谈论我想做什么呢？除非他从这个世界上消失，否则我永远也做不了。
Well, we are now standing in the second parlor of this house on Main Street in Sag Harbor. And I've lived here since 1985. I sold it to Rue, I think, in '95. And I never expected to be alive this long. Poor Rue.
好了，我们现在正站在萨格港主街这栋房子的第二个客厅里。我从1985年就住在这里。我想我在95年把它卖给了瑞。我从没想过我能活这么久。可怜的瑞。
To Ned, who is 78, selling his house from under himself was an ingenious way to stay in a place he considers home. A pianist who made his living as an editor, Ned has spent his life getting money and then spending it all. By the time he put his house on the market he was sick and broke. He didn't have the will to move.
对78岁的内德来说，把他自己的房子卖掉是一种让他留在自己认为家的地方的巧妙方法。作为一名钢琴家，以编辑为生，内德一生都在赚钱然后挥霍掉。当他把房子放到市场上时，他已经病倒且破产了。他没有搬家的意愿。
The Main Street house is the only one he's ever owned. It's crammed with antiques, and oriental rugs, and reminders of his elegant New Orleans upbringing. A large romantic portrait of him from 1951 hangs in the parlor. In the kitchen is a framed photograph of Stillwood, his grandmother's plantation house.
主街的房子是他唯一拥有过的。它挤满了古董、东方地毯，以及他优雅的新奥尔良成长环境的提醒。一张他1951年的大幅浪漫肖像挂在客厅里。厨房里有一张他祖母的种植园房子斯蒂尔伍德的装裱照片。
And the little silver coffee set, this set right here, a little coffee pot, a cream pitcher, and a sugar pitcher, and a tray, my mother said was from the Civil War down in New Orleans. And it's been buried in the garden to keep General Butler, Spoon Butler they called him, to keep it from him. And I said, oh mother, on the bottom of each piece in here it says 1893. And she said, well that's a stock number. In reality, my mother was not to be moved by this.
还有那个小银咖啡具，就在这，一个小咖啡壶，一个奶油壶，一个糖罐，还有一个托盘，我母亲说这是来自新奥尔良内战期间的。它被埋在花园里以避开巴特勒将军，他们叫他“汤匙巴特勒”，以保护它不落入他手中。我说，哦妈妈，这里的每件东西底部都写着1893。她说，嗯，那是库存编号。实际上，我母亲并没有被这个说法打动。
And when I took the tray to a silversmith in New York to have it redone, he said, has this tray ever been buried in the ground? Because there are all sorts of minerals in it that you only find in the ground. And I told him the story. He said, well I bet your mother was right.
当我把托盘带到纽约的银匠那里重做时，他说，这个托盘曾经被埋在土里吗？因为上面有各种各样的矿物质，只有在土里才能找到。我告诉了他这个故事。他说，嗯我打赌你妈妈是对的。
Besides the house and its occasional ailments-- a leaky skylight and overflowing garbage can-- what unites these two households is the anticipation of Ned's death. Back when they first negotiated the deal nobody thought he would still be alive today.
除了房子及其偶发的毛病——漏水的天窗和溢出的垃圾桶——这两个家庭的共同点是对内德死亡的预期。早在他们最初协商这笔交易时，没人认为他今天还会活着。
He had had a heart attack and he had had a history of heart disease, I don't know how long a history. He had had bypass surgery, and then right after the closing, two weeks after the closing, he had another heart attack. And I talked to him from the hospital. And he sounded quite authentically sick I have to say. And that was six years ago.
他患过心脏病，有心脏病史，我不确定病史有多长。他做过搭桥手术，在成交后，成交两周后，他又心脏病发作了。我从医院跟他通过话。我必须说，他听起来确实病得很重。那是六年前的事了。
The trouble is I, all of a sudden, began to get better and was going around full of energy. And I feel perfectly good most of the time. I wake up and I embrace the day so to speak, well not the early day.
问题是，我突然之间开始好转，精力充沛地四处走动。我大部分时间都感觉非常良好。我醒来时拥抱这一天，这么说吧，嗯，不是清晨。
[PIANO PLAYING]
[钢琴演奏]
The contract that binds Ned and Rue has led them to live together separately. They don't consider each other family or even friends. They don't invite each other over for dinner or drop by each other's apartment for a chat. When they do talk, their conversation is almost exclusively about the house. Like considerate roommates, they try not to offend each other with their habits.
绑定内德和瑞的合同导致他们生活在同一个屋檐下却分开居住。他们不认为对方是家人甚至朋友。他们不会邀请对方共进晚餐或顺便到对方公寓聊天。当他们交谈时，谈话几乎完全是关于房子的。像体贴的室友一样，他们尽量不让对方被自己的习惯所冒犯。
I try to figure out when maybe nobody's upstairs and that's when I play. But sometimes I realize they are upstairs, but then I go ahead and play anyhow. I'm sure it must bother them. It would bother me.
我试着想办法，也许楼上没人的时候，那就是我演奏的时候。但有时我意识到他们在楼上，但我还是继续演奏。我相信这一定困扰他们。要是我的话我也会困扰的。
I've played the piano ever since I was nine years old. And I'm very sad by the fact that I can no longer read music because I've forgotten all those pieces that I learned all those years ago. But I now can sit down and simply play what comes out. And oddly enough, sometimes what comes out is very, very nice. It's always very sad. Oh there have been moving evenings here, let me tell you, not a dry handkerchief in the house.
我从9岁起就弹钢琴。让我非常难过的是我再也读不懂乐谱了，因为我已经忘记了所有那些年前学过的曲子。但我现在可以坐下来简单地演奏心里流露出来的东西。奇怪的是，有时流露出来的东西非常、非常美。它总是非常悲伤。哦，这里有感人的夜晚，让我告诉你，屋里没有干过的手帕。
In fact, Rue likes his playing. She's never told him so, but she finds it soothing when the music drifts into her bedroom when she and the baby are taking a nap. And he has never told her that he finds her presence upstairs comforting. Still there are complicated feelings on both sides.
事实上，瑞喜欢他的演奏。她从没告诉过他，但当音乐漂进她的卧室，她和宝宝正在小睡时，她觉得很舒缓。而他也从未告诉过她，他觉得她的存在让楼上感到欣慰。尽管如此，双方都有复杂的感觉。
I do like Ned and I do feel kind of benevolent towards him like I'm taking care of him sometimes. He just inspires that in people. But then I'm not going to be terribly, terribly sorry when he dies. I'm going to be sorry, but I'm also going to feel some relief. It's very strange.
我确实喜欢内德，有时我也对他有一种善意，就像我在照顾他一样。他只是激发了人们的那种感觉。但当他去世时，我不会感到特别、特别难过。我会感到难过，但我也会感到某种解脱。这非常奇怪。
Every time I ask him how are you doing or take care, I always get this little twinge. There is a twinge.
每次我问他你怎么样或者保重时，我总是会有一阵刺痛。有一阵刺痛。
Of?
什么？
A twinge of like how are things going or how are you doing, and just this wicked twinge comes over me because I think that I'd a little bit like to hear not so great.
一阵关于“事情怎么样”或者“你怎么样”的刺痛，一种邪恶的刺痛就向我袭来，因为我想，如果能听到“不太好”的话，我会有点高兴。
Do you think that he's keyed in to this other conversation in your head?
你认为他是否注意到了你脑子里的这种对话？
Well as I said, Ned's no fool.
嗯，正如我所说，内德不是傻瓜。
I'm aware that the other side can't be all that thrilled that I'm still there. But she's been very nice to me. And I think I've been very nice to her I think.
我知道另一方对我还在那里肯定不是那么兴奋。但她对我很好。我想我也对她很好。
Well she obviously likes you.
她显然喜欢你。
Well I hope so because I like her.
嗯，我希望如此，因为我喜欢她。
But she's also waiting for your demise.
但她也在等待你的死亡。
Oh I'm sure.
哦，我肯定。
Does it make you feel guilty that you got better?
你变好了会让你感到内疚吗？
I don't think I feel guilty. Maybe I do. I'm just sorry that there is Rue sitting up there. She can't help but wait, biting her fingernails probably. It ultimately won't matter to me even now. It's a done deal what Rue feels about it. I don't blame Rue or anybody for the fact that I spent all my money. And I don't, in a way, think that I should be blamed because she spent hers. It sounds heartless put this way, and I guess it is. When one begins picking it apart this way it sounds really quite awful, as though I'm just squelching the life of a young couple and now a brand new life.
我不认为我感到内疚。也许有吧。我只是很遗憾，瑞就坐在楼上。她不禁在等待，可能还在咬指甲。对现在的我来说，这最终并不重要。关于瑞对此的感受已经是一个定局。我不怪瑞或任何人，因为我花光了我的钱。而且在某种程度上，我不认为我应该被指责，因为她花了她的钱。这样说听起来很冷酷，我想也确实如此。当一个人开始以这种方式分解它时，听起来真的很糟糕，就好像我只是在扼杀一对年轻夫妇的生活，现在还有一个全新的生活。
A lot of people would say that Rue looks like the heartless one in this arrangement. There she is waiting for a gentleman to die.
很多人会说瑞在这个安排中看起来是冷酷无情的一个。她就在那里等待一个绅士死亡。
That's why I think this kind of speculation, there's a certain falseness about it. Yes, these thoughts flicker across every mind, mine as well as hers I'm sure, but we're civilized beings. I did what I thought I had to do. And I also think that she did what she felt she maybe not had to do, but she did what she wanted to do.
这就是为什么我认为这种猜测有一种虚假感。是的，这些想法闪过每个人的脑海，我的还有她的，我肯定，但我们是文明人。我做了我认为我必须做的事。而且我也认为她做了她觉得她可能不一定非做不可的事，但她做了她想做的事。
[PIANO PLAYING]
[钢琴演奏]
To maintain their relationship, Ned and Rue have developed a careful communication devoid of jokes about arsenic, for example, at least to each other. The result is a textbook defense of civil society, a housebound version of Robert's Rules of Order .
为了维持他们的关系，内德和瑞发展出了一种谨慎的沟通方式，至少在对方之间避免了关于砷的笑话。结果是民事社会的教科书式辩护，罗伯特议事规则的居家版本。
It's been very civilized I think. Rue and I are polite to each other. She doesn't inquire into my problem, and I don't inquire into hers. We don't let our feelings carry us into territory that is uncharted and really will always be uncharted.
我认为这非常文明。瑞和我很礼貌。她不打听我的问题，我也不打听她的。我们不让我们的情绪带我们进入未知的领域，这些领域将永远是未知的。
What territory is that?
那是什么领域？
The territory that she resents the fact that I'm still alive and I resent the fact that she wants me to die. It's supposed to be a total honesty in examining every scrap of the brain, our emotions and whatnot are supposed advance something. But it usually depresses rather than advances I think. I think that we have these rules of society and whatnot for kind of good reasons. It's better to be on the surface than not because it's unanswerable, and it's territory that I'm unable to explore. And I don't think Rue is able to explore it to any benefit either.
她怨恨我还活着，而我怨恨她希望我死的领域。应该在检查大脑的每一个碎片时完全诚实，我们的情绪等等应该有所推进。但我认为这通常会抑制而不是推进。我认为我们有这些社会规则等等，出于某种好的原因。最好在表面上，而不是相反，因为这是不可回答的，而且这是我无法探索的领域。而且我认为瑞也无法探索它来获得任何好处。
Because of his upbringing, Ned comes to this position naturally. But it's remarkable to me that my stepsister, a 70s wild child still known to say things like virtue is a load of crap, has come to understand the power of polite restraint. In private, of course, away from Ned, she's unapologetic about what lurks beneath their relationship.
因为他的背景，内德自然地得出这个立场。但让我惊讶的是，我的继姐，一个70年代的疯狂女孩，仍然以说“美德是一堆狗屎”之类的话而闻名，竟然理解了礼貌克制的力量。当然，在私下里，远离内德，她对自己关系下隐藏的东西毫不道歉。
I don't feel so very guilty about it because I don't feel anything that anybody else wouldn't feel. I know how people are. I'm no worse than anybody. Mother Teresa could be living in this apartment, if she were young with a baby and a husband, and not have those thoughts. OK? I know that.
我并不感到那么内疚，因为我不觉得别人不会有的任何感觉。我知道人们是什么样。我不比任何人差。特蕾莎修女如果住在公寓里，如果她年轻，有孩子和丈夫，也不会有那些想法。好吧？我知道这一点。
It seems to me that people waste an awful lot of time having pretenses about what they're supposed to feel when what they really feel is what they really feel. You can't tell life to be something that it's not going to be, that it isn't. You can't argue with it. I don't mind being just a human being. That's fine.
在我看来，人们把大量的时间浪费在虚伪上，假装他们“应该”感受到什么，而他们真正感受到的是他们真正感受到的。你不能告诉生活去成为它不会成为的东西，那不是它。你不能和它争辩。我不介意只是一个人类。那很好。
[PIANO PLAYING]
[钢琴演奏]
Both Rue and Ned moved into this house hoping it would be the last place where they'd ever unpack. Ned got his wish. But if he survives for more than another year, a strong possibility, Rue will have to move out. Her two small rooms will become too small once her baby starts to crawl. For now though, Rue's proud that the five souls living under her roof are getting along so well. And when Ned finally does die, she says she'll be sad. Along with twinges of wickedness, it's a sadness she bought along with the house.
瑞和内德都搬进这栋房子，希望这是他们永远拆包的最后一个地方。内德实现了他的愿望。但如果他还能再活一年以上——这是一种很大的可能性——瑞将不得不搬走。一旦她的宝宝开始爬行，她的两个小房间就会变得太小了。尽管现在，瑞很自豪，她屋檐下的五条灵魂相处得很好。而当内德最终去世时，她说她会感到难过。连同邪恶的刺痛，这是一种她与房子一起购买的悲伤。
[PIANO PLAYING]
[钢琴演奏]
There you have my Rachmanioff period. Well not really.
这是我的拉赫玛尼诺夫时期。嗯，并不是真的。
Sarah Koenig.
莎拉·柯尼格。
[MUSIC - "LOVE NEST" BY HI LOS]
[音乐 - "LOVE NEST" BY HI LOS]
Act Three, To a De-luxe Apartment in the Sky. One of the producers of This American Life , Blue Chevigny, used to have a job that was all about moving day and people who did not want to face that day. She worked for an agency in New York called Project Reachout, part of Goddard Riverside Community Center. They moved homeless mentally ill people into their own homes. With most of her clients it took years.
第三幕，搬到天上的豪华公寓。《这就是美国生活》的制片人之一，布鲁·切维尼，曾经有一份工作完全是关于搬家日和那些不想面对那一天的人们。她为纽约一家名为“接触计划”的机构工作，那是戈达德·里弗赛德社区中心的一部分。他们把无家可归的精神病患者搬进他们自己的家里。对于她的大多数客户，这需要几年时间。
In April, she went back to New York to watch one of the guys who she knew and liked finally get into his own room.
四月，她回到纽约，看着她认识并喜欢的其中一个家伙终于搬进了自己的房间。
Back at my old job, George stood out from a lot of the other clients. He was immediately easy to relate to. He was more talkative, more expressive, more open with people. One of my old coworkers, Dave Dean, remembers being an intern seven years ago, walking into the basement where all the clients were hanging out, playing cards, not talking much, especially to him. He remembers meeting George.
回到我的旧工作，乔治在许多其他客户中脱颖而出。他立刻就很容易沟通。他更健谈，更富有表现力，对人更开放。我的一位前同事，戴夫·迪恩，记得七年前做实习生时，走进所有客户挂牌子、玩牌的地下室，他们话不多，尤其是对他。他记得见到乔治。
He was very charming. And so the director was introducing me to the clients, introduced me to George. And George asked if I wanted to play pool, and so we played pool. And he was very friendly, very engaged, was going out of his way to make me feel at home as the new intern at the day program.
他非常有魅力。所以主任向我介绍了客户，向我介绍了乔治。乔治问我想不想打台球，于是我们打了台球。他非常友好，非常专注，不遗余力地让我作为日间项目的新实习生感到宾至如归。
Other clients were capable of that kind of warmth after you knew them for a little while. But very few were so friendly from the start. At that time George was living on the street. Eight years went by before he was ready to move into his own place again. What took so long? For one thing, like a lot of mentally ill people, he didn't really mind living outside ever since the day he first became homeless two decades ago.
其他客户在你了解他们一段时间后也能有那种温暖。但很少有人一开始就那么友好。当时乔治住在街上。八年过去了，他才再次准备好搬进自己的地方。为什么花了那么久？首先，像许多精神病患者一样，自从他二十年前第一次无家可归那天起，他就并不介意住在外面。
One day I just got up and just left the place. I just closed the door and broke the key off in the lock, and I just took off to the streets. Now that I think about now, to just leave it the way I did leave it, it shows there are signs of a very sick man, no plans, nothing, closed it, locked the door, and broke the key off, and just leave. I left clothes, rugs on the floor, furniture, everything. I just left it.
有一天我起床就离开了那个地方。我关上门，把钥匙断在锁里，我就跑到街上了。现在想起来，就像我离开时那样离开，表明这是一个非常生病的人的迹象，没有计划，什么都没有，关上，锁上门，把钥匙断掉，直接离开。我留下了衣服、地毯、家具，一切。我就这么离开了。
And you never went back and got that stuff?
你从来没回去取那些东西？
No, I never went back. I was free. I felt like I was free as a bird. I  was free, no responsibilities, nothing. I don't have to pay rent. I don't have to pay gas and light. I go over here and eat what I want when I want it. I go over here and sleep there. I was flying around like a mad man I was so free listening to my Walkman do do do do do do do do do do.
不，我没回去过。我自由了。我觉得我像只鸟一样自由。我很自由，没有责任，什么都没有。我不必付房租。我不必付煤气和电费。我到这边来，想什么时候吃就什么时候吃。我到那边去，想睡哪就睡哪。我像个疯子一样飞来飞去，我太自由了，听着我的随身听，哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒。
Dave would see him in the park looking as out there as anyone you ever see on the streets of New York, in a white unitard, white shirt, white turban, and with gold chains around his neck. Dave and other workers would give him sandwiches, try to lure him back to Project Reachout where he had come for help in the past. It took a long, long time.
戴夫会在公园里看到他，看起来和你在纽约街头看到的任何人一样“出格”，穿着白色连体衣、白衬衫、白头巾，脖子上挂着金链子。戴夫和其他工作人员会给他三明治，试图诱导他回到“接触计划”，他在过去曾从那里寻求过帮助。这花了好长、好长的时间。
And I kept talking with him in the park and saying George, come back. We did it before. We can do it again. Take care of yourself. Come back.
我一直在公园里和他聊天，说乔治，回来吧。我们以前做过。我们可以再做一次。照顾好自己。回来吧。
Dave said, I understand you're free. But life is more than just being free. You can be just as free and more comfortable than sleeping on park benches, hanging out on the subway. And so he talked to me.
戴夫说，我知道你是自由的。但生活不仅仅是自由。你可以像睡在公园长椅上、在地铁里闲逛一样自由，而且更舒适。所以他跟我谈了。
And he was like, I'm not ready, I'm not ready. We went on like that for a while in the park. And then for whatever reason George was ready. And he decided OK, he'll do it. And then he came back one winter.
他当时说，我没准备好，我没准备好。我们在公园里那样持续了一段时间。然后不知为什么乔治准备好了。他决定好的，他会做的。然后他就在一个冬天回来了。
What makes George's case different than a lot of the other people at Project Reachout is that he happens to respond really well to medication. Without it, he says, he's angry all the time.
乔治的情况与“接触计划”中的许多其他人不同之处在于，他恰好对药物反应非常好。他说，没有药物，他整天都在生气。
Anger was built up like I was going to explode all the time. All you had to do was say something, I'd explode on you. Boom. Before my thoughts were all over the place. You could ask me a question then, and 20 minutes later I'd ask you if you asked me a question. Now if you ask me a question I try to answer it if I have an answer. We could sit down, we could talk. I can concentrate on what's going on. But I was a real grouch.
愤怒积聚起来，好像我随时都要爆炸。你只要说什么，我就对你爆炸。砰。在此之前我的思绪到处都是。你可以问我一个问题，20分钟后我还会问你是否问过我问题。现在如果你问我一个问题，我有答案的话我就尽量回答。我们可以坐下来，我们可以谈谈。我可以专注于发生的事情。但我以前是个十足的牢骚大王。
These days if you meet George he looks completely normal and great. He smiles all the time. He looks as if he takes time to put himself together every day. Dave says he looks like a college professor, a 48-year-old African American man with salt and pepper hair, dressing in nice suits or jackets, and looking all studious in eyeglasses. And today he's moving 40 blocks north to his own place.
这些天如果你见到乔治，他看起来完全正常且很棒。他整天都在笑。他看起来好像每天都花时间把自己打理得很好。戴夫说他看起来像大学教授，一个48岁的非裔美国人，有着盐和胡椒色的头发，穿着漂亮的西装或夹克，戴着眼镜看起来很文静。今天他要向北搬40个街区到他自己的地方。
I bet you're not going to miss that dog.
我打赌你不会想念那条狗的。
No, you're right.
不，你说得对。
Dave helps George moved his stuff into a van along with Christina Caine, who coordinates housing for Project Reachout and moves everyone.
戴夫和克里斯蒂娜·凯恩一起帮乔治把东西搬进货车，克里斯蒂娜负责“接触计划”的住房并搬动每个人。
Moving a homeless person usually means carrying a few garbage bags of stuff. For George, it means the van is jam-packed. He has a portable stereo, a TV, and a VCR, things he's bought with disability checks. But the real reason we have to make seven trips up and down the stairs, three people carrying stuff, is his clothes.
搬迁无家可归者通常意味着搬运几垃圾袋东西。对于乔治，意味着货车被塞得满满当当。他有便携式音响、电视和录像机，都是他用残疾补助支票买的东西。但我们需要上下楼梯七次、三个人搬东西的真正原因是他的衣服。
George, your room's got a big closet?
乔治，你的房间有大衣柜吗？
Yeah, a big walk-in closet.
是的，一个很大的步入式衣柜。
You're going to need it.
你会需要它的。
That's the first thing I spotted. I said, oh wow. Look, there's a big walk-in closet.
这是我发现的第一件事。我说，噢哇。看，那里有一个大的步入式衣柜。
For the last year George has been living in a shelter where he doesn't have his own room, a place designed as transitional housing. At some point all of these clients have to move to permanent homes, and it's one of the trickiest parts of my old job. Moving day is what they're all working towards, but in many cases when that day comes, it's been like pulling teeth to get there.
去年乔治一直住在收容所，那里没有他自己的房间，那是个设计为过渡性住房的地方。在某个时候，所有这些客户都必须搬到永久性住所，这是我旧工作中最棘手的部分之一。搬家日是他们都在努力工作的方向，但在很多情况下当那一天到来时，就像拔牙一样困难才能完成。
Most schizophrenics share this quality with some homeowners, they don't like change. They've barely gotten used to the transitional shelter, and now they have to move. One of the guys I was closest to got so mad at me about moving that I gave him a little pep talk about it every day for months, while he just scowled at me, before he'd agree to go. He stayed in the shelter for two years. Christina is the one who now finds housing for these guys.
大多数精神分裂症患者与一些房主有同样的特质：他们不喜欢改变。他们好不容易适应了过渡性的避难所，现在又要搬家。我最亲近的一个家伙对我搬家的事非常生气，我连续几个月每天都给他做一点鼓励谈话，而他只是对我皱眉头，最后才同意去。他在避难所待了两年。克里斯蒂娜现在为这些人找住房。
Some feel like we don't want them anymore, and we want to make room for new people and just get them out. And they have made deep connections with a lot of the workers. And they feel hurt when that relationship changes. It doesn't necessarily end or have to end, although some of them do end it. There was a client who did move, and he never came back. And he won't see me for follow-ups. They do feel abandoned. For a lot of these people, it's their first relationship that was consistent and nonjudgmental, and they don't want to lose that.
有些人觉得我们不再想要他们了，我们想为新来的人腾出空间，就把他们赶走。他们与许多工作人员建立了深刻的联系。当这种关系改变时，他们会感到受伤。它不一定结束或非得结束，尽管有些人确实结束了。有个客户确实搬走了，但他再也没回来。他也不见我做后续跟踪。他们确实感到被抛弃。对这些人中的许多人来说，这是他们第一次一致且非评判性的关系，他们不想失去它。
Because of this, during the move the three of us keep up an ongoing patter of encouragement and positive reinforcement. We open the door to his new place.
因此，在搬家过程中，我们三个人保持着不断的鼓励和正面强化的套话。我们打开了他新地方的门。
This is is so nice.
这太好了。
Home sweet home. Welcome.
金窝银窝，不如自己的狗窝。欢迎。
Thank You.
谢谢。
George, you have air conditioning in here.
乔治，你这里有空调。
We do?
我们有吗？
Look at this closet.
看看这个衣柜。
Yeah.
是的。
The things that are important to, I guess you would say, the average person like having a clean place to stay, I try to stress that. Look how clean it is. And a lot of them are like, so? They lived outside. It's OK if it's not clean to them. So that's a hard selling point to get them out of the shelter. We want them somewhere clean and safe. And to them cleanliness isn't really a priority. If they feel comfortable somewhere, that's the priority.
我想对所谓普通人很重要的事情，比如有一个干净的地方住，我尽量强调这一点。看它有多干净。他们很多人说，那又怎样？他们住在外面。对他们来说不干净也没关系。所以这是一个很难把他们从避难所弄出来的卖点。我们想要他们去一个干净安全的地方。对他们来说，清洁并不是优先考虑的。如果他们觉得在一个地方舒服，那才是优先考虑的。
Even though we all know this, in our need to go on and on about how great the new place is, at some point we run low on material and find ourselves saying--
尽管我们都知道这一点，但在我们不断谈论这个新地方有多好的需求中，在某个时刻我们的素材用完了，发现自己说——
George, look at this bathroom. It's so clean.
乔治，看看这个浴室。太干净了。
And as we ride up in the elevator, George pines for his old room in the shelter.
当我们乘电梯上去时，乔治渴望他在避难所的旧房间。
But I loved my little room over there, Dave. You had to pry me out of it.
但我爱我那边的那个小房间，戴夫。你必须硬把我撬出来。
It will take a little while, but you'll love this one soon, you know? It'll take a while. You probably won't sleep well the first few nights. It's always difficult to sleep in a new place. And that's natural. So that's going to happen. But I think, after a while, you'll like this place better. You'll appreciate it. And then when you go back to visit [UNINTELLIGIBLE], you'll be like, dang, I'm glad I got out of here.
需要一点时间，但你很快就会爱上这个的，你知道吗？需要一段时间。最初几个晚上你可能睡不好。在一个新地方睡觉总是很困难。这很自然。所以这会发生。但我认为，过了一段时间，你会喜欢这个地方多一点。你会欣赏它的。然后当你回去探访时，你会觉得，该死，我真高兴我搬出来了。
I don't know. I remember the first day I moved in there. I looked at those yellow walls. I said, oh drab, yellow walls. Then you couldn't tear me out of it.
我不知道。我记得我搬进去的第一天。我看着那些黄色的墙壁。我说，哦枯燥，黄色的墙壁。然后你都撬不走我了。
Once people have moved inside they sometimes really struggle. And it's all  a bit unpredictable who'll do well and who won't. One guy we moved took six months to figure out how to ride the simple subway commute back and forth to his place each day. But George seems happy with his new room once everything's in it. And the facility is designed for people like him, homeless and mentally ill. The rent is a fixed percentage of his disability check-- about a third. There are staff people there to help him if he needs it. But it's really his own place.
一旦人们搬进室内，有时确实会挣扎。而且谁会做得好，谁做不好，都有点不可预测。我们搬走的一个家伙花了六个月才弄清楚如何每天搭乘简单的地铁往返于他的住处。但乔治在一切安置好后似乎对他的新房间很满意。而且该设施是为像他这样的人设计的，无家可归且患有精神疾病。房租是他残疾支票的固定比例——大约三分之一。那里有工作人员帮助他，如果他需要的话。但这确实是他自己的地方。
Two weeks later I go back to visit George to see how he's doing. He goes back every day to Project Reachout to visit Dave, and get his meds, and to go to his day program.
两周后，我回去探访乔治看看他怎么样。他每天都回到“接触计划”探访戴夫，拿他的药，去参加他的日间项目。
I have it down to a basic science of six minutes, six minutes traveling time from here to Reachout. And I get up in the morning, and I do my thing. I wash my face, brush my teeth, comb my hair, slide into my clothes. I look at the time. I see the train is coming. So I press the elevator. That's how cool it is. I walk real cool and calm to the elevator. It goes ding. And then I go downstairs and I walk around the corner. And then I get to the train station and I hear the train coming, and I have to start flying. Boogidy boogidy boogy boogy. I shoot the metro card through the machine and get on the train. And six minutes later I'm at the corner of Amsterdam and 96th Street on my way into Reachout.
我把它总结成了一个基本的六分钟科学，从这里到接触计划的旅行时间。我早上起床，做我该做的事。我洗脸，刷牙，梳头，穿上衣服。我看时间。我看到火车来了。所以我按电梯。这就是它有多酷。我走得很酷很平静地去电梯。它叮了一声。然后我下楼走到拐角处。然后我到了火车站，我听到火车来了，我就得开始飞奔。跑啊跑，跑啊跑。我把地铁卡通过机器，上了火车。六分钟后我就到了阿姆斯特丹和第96街的拐角处，前往接触计划。
He talks at length about the unlimited metro card pass that he pays for once a month, the pass that lets him ride around the city on the subway and buses as much as he wants and visit his old buddies in the shelter, which he does nearly every day. The city seems full of possibilities.
他详细谈论了他每月支付一次的无限次地铁卡，这张卡让他想怎么骑就怎么骑，在城市里搭乘地铁和公交车，并访问他在避难所的老伙伴，他几乎每天都这么做。这座城市似乎充满了无限可能。
After we finish talking, George walks me to the bus I'm taking to the airport. He says he's never flown in an airplane anywhere, but now that he knows what bus goes out there he thinks he'll go out and watch some planes take off some time. He asks me how I'm doing off in Chicago, a whole new city. I tell him things are good in some ways, not so good in others. I tell him I miss New York. He pats me on the arm. He says it takes some time to get used to things.
交谈结束后，乔治陪我走到我搭乘去机场的巴士。他说他从来没坐过飞机去任何地方，但现在他知道哪趟巴士去那里，他认为他会找时间去看看飞机起飞。他问我在芝加哥过得怎么样，一个全新的城市。我告诉他有些方面还不错，有些方面不怎么好。我告诉他我想念纽约。他拍了拍我的手臂。他说习惯事情需要一点时间。
Blue Chevigny.
布鲁·切维尼。
I go over here and I sleep there. I was flying around like a mad mad I was so free listening to my Walkman, do do do do do do do do do do.
我到那边去，想睡哪就睡哪。我像个疯子一样飞来飞去，我太自由了，听着我的随身听，哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒。
And producer Blue Chevigny spent a while trying to figure out what song it might be that he's singing so she could play it right after. And she came up with many possibilities. Here are just a few.
制片人布鲁·切维尼花了一段时间试图弄清楚他唱的到底是什么歌，以便她能紧接着播放它。她想出了很多可能性。这里仅举几例。
Do do do do do do do do.
哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒。
[MUSIC - "GOT TO GET YOU INTO MY LIFE" BY EARTH, WIND, & FIRE]
[音乐 - "GOT TO GET YOU INTO MY LIFE" BY EARTH, WIND, & FIRE]
This is Earth, Wind, & Fire's Got To Get  You Into My Life. Or is it from Jesus Christ Superstar .
这是大地、风与火的《Got To Get You Into My Life》。或者是来自《耶稣基督万世巨星》。
Do do do do do do do do.
哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒。
[MUSIC - "SUPERSTAR" BY JESUS CHRIST SUPERSTAR ORGINAL CAST]
[音乐 - "SUPERSTAR" BY JESUS CHRIST SUPERSTAR ORGINAL CAST]
Or perhaps Simon and Garfunkel?
或者是西蒙和加芬克尔？
Do do do do do do do do.
哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒。
[MUSIC - "MRS. ROBINSON" BY SIMON & GARFUNKEL]
[音乐 - "MRS. ROBINSON" BY SIMON & GARFUNKEL]
Or maybe Crosby, Stills & Nash?
或者是克罗斯比、斯蒂尔斯和纳什？
Lou Reed.
卢·里德。
[MUSIC - "WALK ON THE WILD SIDE" BY LOU REED]
[音乐 - "WALK ON THE WILD SIDE" BY LOU REED]
And of course our final pick, George Clinton.
当然还有我们最后的选择，乔治·克林顿。
Do do do do do do do do.
哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒。
[MUSIC - "FLASH LIGHT" BY PARLIAMENT]
[音乐 - "FLASH LIGHT" BY PARLIAMENT]
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《这就是美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who, you know, has his own radio show that he does back in his living room about which he says--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，你知道，他自己有一个广播节目，他在他的客厅里做，关于这个节目他说——
There have been moving evenings here let me tell you.
这里有感人的夜晚，让我告诉你。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《这就是美国生活》的故事。
PRI Public Radio International.
PRI国际公共广播电台。